when I was 16 I did a horrible thing and
I have carried that with me this whole
time
Sin Toya Brown was a teenager when she
was found guilty of first-degree murder
and sentenced to life in prison but now
she's getting another chance after
Tennessee Governor Bill Haslam granted
her clemency deeming her sentence too
harsh in a statement he said sin Toya
Brown committed by her own admission a
horrific crime at the age of 16
yes imposing a life sentence on a
juvenile that would require her to serve
at least 51 years before even being
eligible for parole consideration is too
harsh especially in light of the
extraordinary steps miss Brown has taken
to rebuild her life transformation
should be accompanied by hope in 2004
Cynthia Brown was a 16 year old runaway
under the influence of a violent pimp
she killed a man who tried to rape her
after he'd taken her to his home for sex
now 30 years old she says she will do
everything to justify her release Thank
You Governor Haslam for your act of
mercy and giving me a second chance I
will do everything I can to justify your
faith in me her case was the subject of
a social media campaign that went viral
involving multiple celebrities including
Kim Kardashian who has championed her
release since 2017 even meeting with
President Donald Trump to make the case
for clemency Brown will be released on
August 7th under the condition of a
10-year parole and a Brady Sky News